how did you decide what types of pitches
you were looking for yeah so each
Network studio production company
basically has a brand right if you watch
ABC you'll notice that their content is
going to be a little different from CBS
and their content is probably different
from FX and their content is probably
different from the Disney Channel right
so your job as an executive is to get in
there and learn that brand so that means
you're going to watch as much stuff as
you want and you're going to kind of pay
attention in meetings if you're if
you're new so the mandates change
every quarter maybe even sooner than
that and so the EVP
um will inform us okay well we're
looking for this for that maybe it's
going to be Trends but like I've said
before if we're watching the trend it
already happened so it's our job to be
above the uh be ahead of the trend uh
sometimes it's this thing is working for
someone else's Network what's our
version of that and now we're looking
for that uh generally speaking though as
a screenwriter it's your job to be doing
that same kind of work and saying okay
ABC is usually going to have a show
that's like this so does my project fit
that or does my project fit more of the
kind of shows that would be on NBC a lot
of that is about audience and it's about
age and again 20 years ago you probably
couldn't find that on your own now it's
probably on the internet somewhere you
know what I mean to tell you who the
audience is that watches NBC who the
audience is that watches ABC so that you
can know that's not even my audience why
would I pitch there right so sometimes
we would end up having people come in
and Pitch something to us that just
wasn't for us you know what I mean we
tried it um because I worked at the
Sci-Fi channel it was very Niche right
and so people just people look at
science fiction generally but as a
network we have to Define what it was
for us right so for example
um at that time we didn't do horror
right but a lot of people put horror as
a subcategory of Science Fiction so
people would come in and Pitch us horror
stuff all the time well that's not what
we're doing uh one of the mandates while
I was there
um USA had just started doing their um I
think it's characters welcome or
something like that as their uh as their
slogan for the time because they were
now going into more of a a half hour
kind of light dramedy you know kind of
stuff that was very character based and
so we were on the same floor as USA
we're both at NBC Universal so sci-fi
was on one end the universe uh USA was
on the other and for us at science at
sci-fi we were also changing our brand
we were rebranding so we were no longer
s-c-i-f-i but we became s-y-f-y which
was supposed to allow us to be more open
right and so then we kind of changed our
slogan to what if so we wanted people to
consider what if a boy found out he was
a wizard
that could be something on the Sci-Fi
channel right and so with that whole
characters welcome hopefully I'm saying
the slogan correctly but with the whole
characters welcome in the what if we
kind of wanted to make science fiction
versions of USA shows
right and so that was our mandate for
however long so if you came in and
pitched something that was outside of
that that's not what we're looking for
right now if it was super fantastic or
coming in from someone we wanted to work
with then maybe we'd buy it develop it
and see what would happen right but we
already knew this is the kind of stuff
that we're looking for for right now and
so also in those General meetings that I
mentioned earlier if you're taking a
general meeting as a screenwriter ask
what are you looking for even before you
start I don't think you should be
pitching in a general meeting anyway
that's not what it's for that's not why
you're there you're there to get to know
each other that's all it is right but if
you do have some things that you think
that you would like to send over to them
first ask what are you looking for
that way you won't waste your time or
theirs by sending something that they're
not even looking for but within that
even if they're only looking for certain
things right now but you understand
their overall brand you still might say
okay that's great well I have this is
that something that you're interested in
seeing right because even though we're
not looking for zombies at the time if
you know that we had a great zombie show
two three years ago maybe it'll come
back down the pipeline at some other
point where we'll be looking for job for
zombies and so you still might want to
say okay well I have the zombie thing
are you interested in seeing it they can
still say no but now you're not too off
the market because you know that off the
mark because you know that they do
zombie stories here but to say hey can I
send you guys something about a lion
well that's not what we do here right so
now you have proven that you haven't
done your side of the research to know
what fits for this particular brand you
know so we as executives are when we're
first getting there to learn the brand
or doing the same kind of research that
you as a writer should be doing to learn
the brands of the places where you want
to pitch
and would you say a network uh does a
rebranding
um
that's a good question I think uh I
don't think there's a number that you
can put on it but I think like most
companies right like how many times have
you seen McDonald's change what they
look like you know what I mean but those
arches don't change right they're still
the same marches you're not going to
lose that but I think it just depends on
how it's changing with the times you
know what I'm saying um the peacock has
changed a little bit over at NBC
Universal but at the same time I don't
even know if they're NBC Universal
anymore because they've been bought by
Comcast at one point when I worked there
they uh they were General Electric so GE
owned NBC Universal when I was there so
those kind of things can make you have
to kind of Rebrand Etc but I really
think it just depends on what you want
for the network if you get a new uh
president who has a different Vision you
know they may try to change some things
around like if you look at the CW which
was you know UPN at one point and the WB
at another point and all of those things
and it rebranded over and over and over
and now it's been the CW for quite some
time will they change it again who knows
but they did change their programming
mandates they used to have far more uh
shows of people of color a decade ago
than they do now because they changed
what Their audience was maybe because
someone came in and said hey we just
want to do something different who knows
but you know I think that's the thing
that you have to stay on top of as a
writer right because as a writer if I'm
creating a you know teen show about
people of color maybe I'll take it to CW
but right now I don't really have much
proof that they would even be interested
in it not to say that they don't have
anything about people of color but if
you look at the DraStic difference over
the you know last decade or so in their
content then I might say to myself maybe
I don't go there maybe instead I go to
free form you know what I mean so you
just kind of have to just stay with the
times because you don't know what's
going to make them change but I would
you know look at something like uh NBC
ABC CBS they've kind of been a staple so
even if the color of their logo changes
or you know some font changes or again
the peacock changes Their audience has
basically been the same now I've heard I
don't know if it's true that CBS is
going to try to start uh programming a
little more outside of Their audience
Their audience tends to skew a little
older which is why they have a lot of
procedural shows because people of that
generation tend to like I know what I'm
going to get every week right and so
supposedly they're going to try to you
know push out of that a little bit I
don't know if that's going to cause the
entire place to Rebrand but it'll change
the Mandate for the programming that
they're looking for and just like with
Netflix they seem to be taking a lot of
foreign titles and making them into
series or you know based on a short or
whatever yep and so then they have
subtitles so that that seems like a
newer thing maybe yeah yeah I mean I
think
it's easier and less risky to do
something that's already established
right so if that International Film did
well somewhere else then maybe it'll do
well here you know what I mean so I you
know when it comes to streamers they can
uh program in so many different ways
right I'm not sure what their mandates
are sometimes I can't even tell when I'm
watching some of the streamers and I
won't say which ones but I'm watching
and I'm going what kind of programming
can I expect here like I just don't know
right whereas you know I'll use Netflix
as an example I can watch something you
know see a trailer and go oh that's a
Netflix film like I can feel
that it feels like Netflix to me right
and then there are other you know uh
Hulu Hulu does a great job with their
limited series they're um uh kind of
biopic or based on a true story kind of
limited series I can see now from a
trailer and go that looks like it's
going to be on Hulu right just like you
could if you were looking at something
that was on any other cable network but
I do think
because uh when when you're a streamer
you're thinking about where all of your
Revenue can come from right so you have
a subscription maybe like some didn't
used to have a subscription now they
have them and they keep increasing it
right because you got to keep making
your money uh do we have commercials do
we only make content which means now
we're spending all of our money or do we
also accept content from other places
and so now uh we get to
utilize that content to do what we want
to do to make more money do we now
acquire you know uh other content to put
on on our on our streaming service and
so I think because there's so many
options and uh streamers unlike your
basic cable television reaches the world
so now your audience is larger right so
now it's not just us who's watching this
what we would consider an International
Film with subtitles because somewhere
else in the world they're watching it at
the same time and it's it's you know
it's in their language you know what I
mean so there's just so much that they
can program to and so because of that we
have so much content out now and I talk
about this often because I don't know if
that's a good thing or a bad thing right
I think it's great that there's a place
for everyone I think it's great that
um globally we're able to see what other
people are doing in in their countries
when it comes to filmmaking but I also
feel like we're being stretched thin in
the amount of content we can take in you
know we can't be on top of all of it we
can't watch all of it right like it gets
to the point where you could be standing
right next to someone who is the series
regular on a very
um popular show
that you've never seen
you know what I mean and so when I think
about it like that I'm like I don't know
where the industry is going to go you
know with all of this content and us
being able to keep up with it and how
expensive it is and you see people are
laying off people and you know trying to
figure out how they're gonna you know uh
change around their budgets Etc so
there's just so much going on with the
industry right now